you can now customize your tungl me
account with your own logo and colors
here's how click public profile at the
top and then Mouse over the personalized
tab on the left click upload your logo
and then choose file in the
popup select the image you want to
upload and then click the upload
button you'll now see a preview on the
top left of what your logo will look
like you can resize it here
and once you're happy click save
image tungle will automatically select
colors for you from the image you
uploaded if you want to change them use
the change buttons on the
right use the sliders and your cursor to
select your new color and then click
select once you're happy with all your
choices click
enable you'll now see your logo and your
colors on your profile page which is
exactly what your visitors will see when
they visit your profile but that's not
all you get send a meeting invitation
from your newly branded account and it
will look something like
this all emails you send your contacts
through tungle such as reminders
invitations confirmations or sharing
requests will be branded with your logo
and colors